all right how are you guys doing
thank you you know why this is such an
amazing day
all right first of all we're going to
talk about phases
and um there are
two lectures that i have uh introduced
this semester that are new
that have never been seen before until
right now
one of them is this one right dang
thank you and then check this out in
this morning
over the wires comes this news
and and it's the nobel prize in
chemistry this year was given
to three of sort of the founders of
lithium-ion batteries
and the other new lecture that i'm
giving this semester later on
is on the chemistry of batteries it's
like
coincidence i don't think so
did someone in stockholm no
i don't know but it's really really cool
and this is awesome and there's so much
great stuff online now about lithium-ion
batteries
because of this i mean there was before
but there's a lot of press on this now
it's very interesting to read about
okay so now um what
what is happening i say the word boiling
all the time
right i've been saying it all the time
especially the last like week
um and and i mean at home too i'm saying
boiling a lot and
and it's because it's a proxy for bond
strength intermolecular bond strength
and boiling i've been kind of going back
and forth right
but so today we're going to go what is
happening when you boil
all right well you know that you're
you're changing a phase as you can see
from this highly accurate
drawing of water molecules in the gas
phase water molecules in the liquid
phase
but what's really under the hood and and
of course the story starts
with otto now who was
otto otto von gurik
otto von gurk in the 1600s
he was like you know what aristotle
aristotle
he was all about like nature abhors a
vacuum
does it really i don't know i don't you
know
does nature really hate like let's try
some stuff out let's try to make a
vacuum and see what happens
so he figured out a way to take these
two hemispheres
these two big bowls and kind of pull all
the air out there he is he looks very
happy there
right um and he's pulling because he's
pumping the air out
inside of here and look what he did he
went around the countryside in germany
and he
he would attach because i'm tight you
just attached eight horses to one side
and eight
horses to another 16 horses pulling
eight that way eight that way and they
couldn't pull it apart
this is what he did it doesn't look like
he's got a lot of
crowd but maybe he did better i don't
see any houses either
i don't know where he is but that that's
the experiment that he did
all throughout the countryside and he
called it
the power of the vacuum nature reports
the fact
the power of the vacuum the power of the
vacuum it's not the power of the vacuum
oh otto it's not the power of the vacuum
because vacuum has no power and nature
doesn't hate it
but pressure so atmosphere has
power technically it has force
atmosphere has pressure what he showed
in that experiment
and if there's one experiment i want you
to remember from this class
it's not this one but this is a cool one
but what he showed wasn't the power of
the vacuum he showed the power of one
atmosphere of pressure he showed the
power of pressure
and so we start pressure is force
over area typical units would be like
newtons
per meter squared right
and if you're going newtons per meter
squared then this is called a pascal
and for reference if you have
one pascal one pascal
it's about the pressure of a dollar bill
one dollar resting on a table
i don't know why do i use that one
because i remember it
one dollar resting on a table and so so
that's the force per
area of the bill resting on a table so
if you had a hundred thousand of them
right if you had a hundred thousand of
them and you stacked them up then that's
one atmosphere
it's just a different unit it's about a
hundred thousand pascals
so the power that he was
exhibiting in this experiment is the
power of the atmosphere
we've got we've got atmosphere
all around us pushing on us
it's pushing on us and and so what we
got like a car
worth of atmosphere literally on us but
it's
pushing on us in all different
directions and we're pushing back
luckily we've got stuff inside of us
so we don't like implode right
but that that force is strong and that's
a demonstration of how strong
how much one atmosphere is
right it's force per area the power of
one atmosphere
well that's also directly related to
boiling and how do we get from here to
boiling
well yeah so we need a couple of
concepts right so first
we need the concept of
evaporation and i'm going to use this um
i'm going to use this example of like
water molecules
right so this is a buck this is a glass
of water
right and so if i have a glass of water
i'm going to draw them like these little
things you know and now molecules kind
of near the surface
well it could leave and that is that's a
molecule
not a v right and that's evaporation
evaporation
evaporation but you know
the other way you could go is you could
say well what if there was this liquid
here and you got these molecules
kind of like that and you had one here
and it kind of comes back well that's
condensation
you guys kind of know this right
condensation
evaporation and condensation oh but this
is not what's interesting
i mean it's interesting yeah but it's
but it's more interesting now if you
close it off
and so let's do that with these super
amazing um
animations here there there look at that
okay so now what i've done i got a
liquid and a solid and in both cases
there's a liquid you could have a solid
molecules can come off we'll get to that
how why
but they can come off but now i've
closed it
now if i close the container what would
happen if i
start with nothing so now i start with
the liquid and i close it in a container
you see
look at the molecules they're kind of
coming off and maybe they'll hit the
walls they'll bounce around maybe
at some point they'll come back into the
liquid
right okay so evaporation
went that way condensation went that way
now ah
now if i were to plot
if i were to close this and plot
for example a rate and i say well i want
to know how quickly
evaporation is happening yeah it's just
going to keep happening
i mean i'm starting with with you see in
the videos
these videos are real
you see it doesn't stop happening right
it keeps happening so if i have no vapor
in there to begin with well then okay
evaporation is going to go like this
right maybe this is time it is time
and then so that's evaporation
but then you know at a certain time
point i'm going to have enough
gas molecules gas water molecules in
there you know so
it starts out at zero and they're gonna
build up in there
and a certain point you got that right
and so this would be condensation
okay we're starting with the basics
condensation
right what and then at a certain point
they reach what's called dynamic
equilibrium
dynamic equum equim is equilibrium
so so the dynamic equilibrium is really
important because what happens there
is nothing is stopping it's not that
things stopped you can see it in the
videos
i found it online so it must be right
so so like you know it's continually
going it's a dynamic process it's a
dynamic equilibrium but they are equal
that point that happens in these
containers
you can measure the pressure that is
very important
right and because it's exerting a
pressure on the container
it's exerting a pressure on the liquid
pressure
atmosphere pressure inside of a closed
container
vapor pressure p vapor
that happens when you hit that dynamic
equilibrium now why am i telling you all
this
well the vapor pressure is going to be
how we understand phase change
um and so and so
you know you got to get a sense already
kind of get a sense already that this is
going to be
related this is related
you know this depends
on the bonding all right so i just told
you that water was really special
so so that means that how it it's the
bonding between the water molecules and
how
how often can it get out of the liquid
it's related to the bonding
right so if you if you take
molecules that we talked about on monday
these are just for monday propane
and butane now you understand
right why is there this difference in
the vapor pressure of protein
propane and the vapor pressure of butane
well it's how they bond together and you
know exactly why
because these are only able to do london
and so this has a lot as a higher
surface area we talked about this in
terms of the boiling point remember
as a proxy for the intermolecular
bonding strength but now i'm giving you
the vapor pressure
so this is the vapor pressure of these
things is different those are measure
those are given in kilopascal let's put
so if it's water
so so the water vapor pressure
right let's see make sure i get this
value ah yes
p that i'll just put a pv
for water is about 2.3
kilopascal so it's a lot lower
than those right those are now that in
atmospheres and this is going to be
important
0.02 atmospheres
just switching around units that's all
it's the same thing
as in tight right so so now if if a
liquid
is you can you can think about this as
well this is a proxy
already i can understand this
conceptually right it's a proxy for the
intermolecular bonding
um if you take something like glycerol
well glycerol is uh let's draw glycerol
just for fun
carbon carbon o-h
uh let's see it's got another carbon o-h
it's got another o-h look at all that
ohs it's got some hydrogens down here
it's got another hydrogen in there and
it's got two more hydrogens out here no
i am not paying attention to vesper
right now
i'm just getting it on the board but
look ah but look at that
right away you're like oh look at those
hydrogen bond
opportunities yeah this could bond more
strongly than water to itself right
it's got all that hydrogen bonding it's
got even more than water
and so the vapor pressure of this is
0.01
pascal so much lower
and as a general rule we like to compare
everything to water
so you know if something has a vapor
pressure
that is uh higher than water
so it's called volatile p
v greater than p v water
it is volatile it's a volatile liquid
like butane and propane if it's less
than
pv water then
it's called here comes all those
chemists
non-volatile look at that
look at that beautiful naming
originality
okay but this is the thing right i've
given you this concept of vapor pressure
i've talked about it a little bit you
can relate it to something you just
learned on monday
but i still have not come back to
boiling
and and that really is it it's that
boiling is actually
understood by vapor pressure
that is how we understand boiling and
and so
you can think about let's just give you
conceptually right so if the
if if you had let's go back to those
buckets there
let's go back to like evaporation
condensation but now instead of being in
a closed container
right now i'm outside so if i had
let's say i had this container here and
i've got all these waters in it
right um but now i'm outside so i've got
the power
of one atmosphere right one
atmosphere well it you know now you see
like okay if a molecule is able to
evaporate from the liquid
if a molecule is able to leave the
liquid bonding environment
breaking the bond that's why we can
relate it to intermolecular forces right
it's breaking those bonds in the liquid
and becoming a gas phase molecule it's
changing its phase
well you know then the question is is it
like gonna what's it gonna do
you know is it gonna kind of hang out
here and and are the forces of the
atmosphere
is is the atmospheric pressure going to
kind of hold it around there
or is it going to be able to lean
well this is a very simple conceptual
picture right
is it if you thought that the forces of
the atmosphere were going to always hold
it there then you'd say the atmosphere
is a container and it's not but actually
evaporation only happens because a
breeze can come along and blow this away
right out in the air so those forces
are super important because as soon as
the vapor pressure
is greater than the atmospheric pressure
well now
you can get a sense that if the vapor
pressure is greater than the pressure
outside over that surface of the air
here
then the molecule is just going to fly
right out and power through it
that is the definition of boiling
boiling is a pressure effect it's that
the vapor pressure
of this material which is related to how
strongly it's bonded in the liquid
compared to the gas phase
that that goes higher than the
surrounding pressure
that's the definition of boiling
but i still and so you can see why water
doesn't boil if i
have a bucket of water and i watch it
it's not going to boil .02 atmospheres
is not greater than one
right but so i haven't gotten there yet
i haven't made it boil but i want to
make it boil
and that is where we go next because
that is really what temperature is
see the the vapor pressure is really a
link
between temperature and boiling it's the
length that you need to understand
between temperature
and boiling the reason why
when you increase the temperature of the
water the reason why it boils
is because you change its vapor pressure
that's why it boils that's what boiling
is
okay it's when you get it above the
atmospheric pressure
ah no
okay so so the the
so we got okay so we where there we go
oh we'll come to that in a minute
so if i were to plot now the vapor
pressure let's do this carefully here
okay i'm going to make a plot of the
vapor pressure
pv right versus
temperature so i just told you there's a
dependence on the temperature
right so versus temperature let's go to
well i don't know let's go to room
temperature right so around here
and i just told you that it's 0.02
for 25c
okay good so it's 0.02 for 25
0.02 for 25 c so that's the vapor
pressure
that's the temperature but i also told
you that boiling
if i'm at so this is this is zero but i
also
told you that boiling so this would be
like one atmosphere
let's suppose the units are atmospheres
all right
okay so i i told you that boiling
happens now we know that water we know
what the answer is right
up here that's got to be boiling for
100 c right that's where
the water goes above or meets the
atmospheric pressure and then goes above
it
so once the vapor pressure so this is
the vapor pressure of water
this is what we have so far yeah but we
need more than that
now so he said well why is it
so we know this why is it that if i go
to denver
the so so like this is in boston this is
in boston
this is boston but if i live in denver
how many people live in denver
well i mean you're not living there now
but but welcome to boston
oh and if i go like this
um now see the thing is now
um you boil at this is this is the this
is in denver
well so you guys don't have as much air
in denver
the the the pressure in denver
is 0.83 0.83
atmospheres but i just said that
you know you boil when you have the
vapor pressure is higher than
the atmospheric pressure so that means
whatever this curve is it means that i'm
going to boil at a different temperature
and it turns out that's a hundred and if
you're in denver
it takes longer to boil potatoes
because the boiling temperature is 95.
that's why
but it's all because of this it's all
because of how evaporation
happens as it relates to the atmospheric
pressure
yeah but so the thing is though what we
need and by the way
it you know it you go the other way too
right you can go up
if you go below sea level then the
atmospheric pressure is higher so if you
go to the dead sea
your water boils at 101.4 if you go to
the top of mount everest it's
70. you never boil potatoes there well
you can but you'll never cook
so so how do you how does this get
connected
that's really the question what is so
what is this
right where does that where does that
dependence come from and that's
where we need something called kinetic
theory now i'm not going to
teach you kinetic theory and i'm not
going to say that you're responsible for
knowing it but i'm showing you
what it means what kinetic theory does
which you would learn in say like a
thermal class
right well what kind of kinetic theory
does is it gives us this relationship
between how many molecules have a given
energy in this case it's a kinetic
energy
right and the temperature that's what
kinetic theory does for us so
so let's see if i had um
[Music]
if i had uh to write this
in us in a kind of just simple
dependence way what it's telling us
as in in general is so this would be
kinetic theory
kinetic theory of gases if you want
that's what we're talking about
there okay this would give us
the following this is what what you get
is that the log
of the fractions
fraction of molecules
with some energy e okay
with energy i'll write it out just so
there's not confusion energy
e the log of that the natural log of
that
is going to go as that energy divided by
temperature
it gives you a connection between what
i'm plotting here really that's where
that plot comes from
okay the fraction of molecules with
kinetic energy e
goes as that energy divided by
temperature
the log of that that's what kinetic
theory gives me now and that that fills
it in
except that i still is in vapor pressure
right this still isn't vapor pressure
and so for that
you need one more piece and ah
and that is given to us by clausius
cleperone so the clausius clapeyron
equation ah
does not i'm not going to derive it you
don't need to know how to derive it
um but it goes from the kinetic theory
to vapor pressures
so this one tells us that the log of
the vapor pressure equals minus
and here we go this is the next really
important concept
the heat of vaporization we'll get to
this in a second
divided by r t plus a constant
so that's the ideal gas constant that's
the temperature
and this is the enthalpy or the heat
of vaporization so it's the energy
to vaporize a liquid
good now you know often this is given in
per mole
so it'd be like the energy of vaporizing
a mole of a liquid but it's an energy
it's an amount of energy needed to turn
it
whatever you got to put into it to turn
it into a gas from a liquid
that's that enthalpy of vaporization and
r is the ideal gas constant in this case
you know so if if it's r if
r is in the equation it's got to be per
mole right
because it's r remember we've already
talked about that
since it's r it's the ideal gas constant
so that's now okay
so that is the that is how you get
between
that is how you get this relationship
you get it and again you
you know this is an important equation
you get it from
the kinetic theory of gases but this is
what the outcome is for us
this is what matters is the cautious
clapper on equation
and so and so now what so you can
actually now
if if somehow you knew how much energy
it took to vaporize a mole of this stuff
well now you've got a curve that's all i
need to know
right is how much energy so so now i can
say well let's see
um that's okay i got uh i got you know
maybe uh butane is gonna go like this
and then glycerol might go you know like
that maybe this is propane
right propane uh glycerol
and so on yeah but i'm still missing
this concept
so i can i can now get dependence but
how do i get delta h
that's the next piece of the puzzle
right how do i get delta h
okay so you know so so far i've got this
really cool result right i've got that
p so so far i've got that um
i'm i'm going back to bowling but i'm
going back to boiling
right for boiling i know
that um yeah so so the i am and so p
vapor is related to the imf's
right i know that p
vapor is related to the temperature
and i know that the atmospheric pressure
is important right atmospheric pressure
is uh is related to boiling yeah
okay that's redundant because you got to
get higher than the atmospheric pressure
to boil
that's how we defined it so but again
the specific dependence is what i wanted
on temperature and i have it except that
i now need to know what this delta h
is okay so so here's here we go
why is this related to pizza
everything's related to pizza
at the end of the day but see now we
need to talk about delta h
and what it means and
you know the the way the the easiest way
to show what it means is to plot
how this relates to phase change how
heat
right that's how we're changing phase
here with temperatures
we're changing the temperature we're
adding uh
heat into the system what does it do
what does it do
well you know so one type of plot that
you can make for that
would be temperature versus
thermal thermal energy
input now a lot of times what you'll see
in textbooks is they call that q
it's an energy term so it's like in
joules right let's say
but it's how much thermal energy you put
in then you can draw it out like this
right so
you if you draw it out then you would
have your phases so this would be like a
gas
a liquid a solid and these
would be phase changes
this and that so i'm adding thermal
energy into the system
it's raising the temperature of the
system that's why these are going up
and the solid is getting hotter and then
all of a sudden it melts okay good so it
melted
melts oh and then it's a liquid and all
of a sudden it vaporizes
right vaporize you could go the other
way
if you go the other way it's
condensation out here right or freezing
in here
melting freezing vaporization
condensation but i like to draw it this
way
because this way we're going to see very
nicely what delta h
is so here's now i'm going to draw it
with temperature on the x-axis
so temperature and this is going to be
h and i'm drawing this as the thermal
energy
let's see write it in the same terms
right so this is thermal energy
now in this case thermal energy
um we use this this this
thing called enthalpy enthalpy but
so you don't need to worry too much
about it just see for this class
you can think about it as the thermal
energy content of the material
so if i have a change in that well it's
because i've lost or gained thermal
energy
right right if you take a thermal class
you'll learn a lot more about enthalpy
you know and that this is true only if
you have constant pressure conditions
but that's not relevant here
i just want you to know this is like
this
okay but this is the total thermal
energy
in your material and and and
by the way you know uh q
heat the word heat is q
that is the definite heat means thermal
energy
transfer thermal energy transfer a flow
of heat that makes sense but you cannot
say that this has
10 joules of heat no don't say that you
will sound like you're from another
school
you don't have you have that much
enthalpy
yeah but not that much heat is a
transfer of thermal energy please
okay now here we go all right so let's
suppose
i were to draw this well now i'm gonna
have the same i'm gonna have phases
right and so here we go here we go
here we go and this is my gas and this
is my liquid
and this is my solid and there's a
couple of cool things right so now
so that's the thermal energy h but so
now if i were to take
part of the solid like that and just
look at it while it's a solid
i'm adding thermal energy to it
i'm increasing its temperature we got a
way to relate those things it's called
the heat capacity
right it's called the heat capacity
so if i look at that
i can do that let's go here right
if i look at that then i can relate
those by
well i'm using q because it's a change
right that's the change
in the enthalpy right that's the energy
transfer it goes as the heat capacity
times
the change in the temperature that s
just means it's the heat capacity of the
solid
that literally that's the definition of
heat capacity
right this would be like units of joules
per kelvin
okay and so you know an example of heat
capacity i love pizza
and and so an example of heat capacity
is the following
you burn hopefully you don't but if you
take it out of the oven
and you take a bite right away you will
burn the roof of your mouth on the
cheese
on the cheese because cheese has a lot
of water in it compared to the crust
and water has a really high heat
capacity
what is heat capacity it's the capacity
of it to have
thermal energy and the water has a
really high one
anomaly and so when you take this out
everything's at the same temperature for
just an instant they're all at the same
temperature you should
if you ate it right here please don't
you burn your mouth on the crust the
same way as on the cheese but since
you're waiting now the crust gives out
it doesn't have much heat capacity so it
all goes away all that thermal energy
leaves
very quickly from the crust but not the
cheese because it's got so much more and
if we want to get a little more serious
about it we can talk about the oceans
and so i put this in here because you
know we talk a lot about climate change
what you're talking about are
the the temperatures of the atmosphere
we talk about that a lot
but what gets sort of shoved aside is
the temperature of the ocean
and and that is rising and it's not
rising that quickly luckily but that's
because the ocean has such a high heat
capacity that's
where most of this thermal energy is
going
it's going into the ocean right and we
need to start talking about that a whole
lot more
because it's it's a lot higher than it
used to be
this is the historical reference pretty
flat
you know when a volcano erupts you know
500 years ago you get a blip this big
now we're here right so the amount of
thermal energy this ocean is holding for
us is
very high okay now so that's heat
capacity that's that's kind of
you know an important part but look the
other thing we have here
ah is this and that's what i wanted to
talk about
this is that delta h now in this case
it's it's the change in energy of of
fusion
and because you're fusing to make a
solid in this case
it's called delta h of vaporization you
could call it
um condensation vaporization
station
that's the thing we needed and now you
see it so beautifully
right you see it so beautifully right
there because
now you see it you know so
what is it that causes me to need to put
a lot of energy
into a material to change its bonds so
that it can vaporize
it's all about the bonding strength
right it's all about the bi
everything comes to the bonding strength
right and so i have these kind of two
things right within
one phase within one phase
i can relate delta h to delta t
and and that relationship is here i'm in
the solid phase
i can relate them that's actually called
sensible heat
sensible heat it's the energy that you
would give off when you cool or it's the
energy that you'd absorb when you heat
but now i've got this other thing which
is at the phase change
at the phase change well now the
temperature doesn't change but i'm
putting
all of this energy in or getting it all
out
that's what delta h is right so delta t
is zero
because the temperature is constant and
delta h
is sort of generally called the latent
heat latent heat
if you're talking about the phase change
between a solid and look at the heat of
fusion
heat of melting if you're talking about
the between the
liquid and gas is vaporization or
condensation so that's that energy
change and it's
it's related to well what we've been
talking about but here it is in a nice
diagram
all right now where do we go from here
well there's something so cool about
this graph that i can show you really
easily
ah and i can also tell you how to do
this which is that things can
these are the phase change transition
temperatures but things don't need to
transition at those in fact
oftentimes you might get something like
that
not as much in the gas but liquid to
solid you certainly can get it
this is called super cold why
because for some reason that we didn't
do it but for some reason it's remained
a liquid below its phase change
temperature
here's water super cold poured into a
glass it's one of the most fun things
you can do in life
there it is it's a liquid as soon as it
hits the glass it's like wait a second
i want to be a solid i'm over here
i'm over here i need to be a solid
and and you can do this you can make
sure i can tell you how to make it
you can make super cool water at home
it's really fun
but that was you're doing there now you
know is you're bringing this
down below the phase change and it's
remaining liquid and then all of a
sudden it hits the glass it's like
what what am i doing i need to solidify
right okay so the reason why all this
matters is heat
is a big deal ninety percent and you
know this is you can study this there's
a wonderful charts to study but
you know depending on what you want to
do heat is almost always involved heat
being a transfer of thermal energy
and so so 90 of the current energy
budget basically goes through the middle
in some way that's a lot
but then if you look at things like this
which you shouldn't because you can't
read it but if you blow up these are all
the inputs on the left
all the ways we make energy here's how
we use it
and here's the result here's what i want
to get the punch line is
rejected energy whatever these units
doesn't matter it's 60 percent
what does rejected energy mean wasted
all this precious fossil fuel stuff
we're burning and all the solar energy
we're collecting anything we're doing
here
sixty percent of it goes into heat
wasted heat
and so the reason why this matters is
because there are these materials
that we can use to try to capture some
of that
right there are materials we can use to
try to capture some of that and all
comes down to chemistry
these are called phase change materials
and if you plot the melting temperature
that's this that's this melting
temperature right
tm versus how much of its delta h
how much delta h you have you get all
sorts of classes and materials
but you know so you might want a certain
melting temperature for wherever you're
operating but then you might not get
a high enough delta h or you might want
really high delta h's but then the thing
doesn't melt until 700 c
which is way too high so we got to fill
this out we need materials here we need
materials here that's a call to
chemistry
that's a call to chemistry yeah so this
and it all has to do with the phase
change
these are it's a weird name these are
called phase change materials
but that's true of all materials but
here
when you're talking about storing
thermal energy we use the term phase
change materials
okay now the last concept that i'll just
touch on and then spend a little time on
friday on
is the concept of a map
these are maps these are maps but you
can go even bigger
and and back in the day back in the day
pvt was a big deal you went to a party
you were going to talk about pvt
you were and and you know and so
everybody had their own way of looking
at it guy was sac p versus t but look
if i do p versus t and hold volume
constant right i might get like a line
there
like p if this is pressure all right and
this is temperature
you might get something like p versus t
is a straight line if you hold other
stuff constant right that's good but
that's not what i'm interested in today
i'm interested in where the phase
boundaries are
right this is a materials map
and and it gives me the boundary that's
what this
is all about that's what this was all
about because
look that's why i went through all this
you boil
what is boil phase change phase change
you boil when pv
is greater than p at moon
so so so that is the phase boundary it's
when you have both
the gas and the liquid coexisting where
is it
[Music]
there it is because i can get my my
pressure of vaporization
if i only know this or vice versa
right and then i get that and i said ah
it's up here that's the face boundary oh
yeah that's all cool but this is where
it's at i want to know where stuff
changes phase
right and of course you know you can go
further
and i got to show you something here
there's a couple more things about these
are called phase diagrams
right okay these are maps of materials
and they are beautiful things
and incredibly important and and there's
a couple
last uh points one of which i want to
share now and then the other
i'll share on on friday um but the one i
want to share now is the triple point
so look at this here's the gas liquid
boundary line that's what we've been
talking about
and you also got the solid liquid
boundary line that's here
you've got gas liquid here delta h
there's delta h
you also have sublimation so you go
straight from a solid to a gas and you
have deposition
you go straight from again but look at
this there's one point
where they all coexist one and only one
where all three phases exist at the same
time that's pressure
that's temperature and and and what's so
cool about this is there's only one for
this material and so it actually is a
really nice way
to have a repeatable reproducible point
which i'll get to in a second but first
you got to see this this
is the triple point and what they're
doing
is they're lowering the pressure and the
temperature they're changing both
you can just do this with one or the
other yeah
there it is okay how did they get it to
boil lower the pressure
you now know why you lower the
atmosphere inside the container
you lower that so you went like this you
went down
and all of a sudden you converted some
of the liquid to gas
because you went down in pressure and
then you said well okay but wait a
second
i'm only seeing these two phases so let
me do this
and go over that way i'm getting closer
closer okay what's happening now and
then do this right
and you're trying to find this special
point here
and they're going close to it they're
going close to it and then a couple
minutes
go by that look it's freezing it's
freezing it's
but wait a second i thought i said
triple point and i did
it's boiling and freezing at the same
time
it is boiling and freezing at the same
time yes that is actually what all
materials can do
that is incredible somebody just said
what thank you for making
my day that makes my day that is a
triple point
we got a one or two more things to talk
about phase diagrams we'll do that on
friday
have a great rest of your day this is
where we left off
um and so i want to start right here and
because the triple point is just so
incredibly cool i found another random
video and i thought i'd show that
so this is where we left off and here it
is and and what they're doing
they they might be controlling the
temperature they're definitely
controlling the pressure
right they have a liquid in here now
watch what happens we know now
from the phase diagram that you can find
those boundaries on the diagram so
they're lowering the pressure
and um and at some point yeah nothing's
going to happen
there okay now it's playing and so at
some point this is going to start to
freeze
because i'm crossing over the boundary
right i'm crossing over the boundary and
and so when you cross over
when you get to a phase boundary you've
got two phases
coexisting oh and there it starts
freezing so you've got the liquid and
the solid phase coexisting but there's
but now can it coexist with also the gas
and at one point of pressure and
temperature again there it is it's kind
of boiled a little bit
i like this one because it kind of goes
big boil so here it is it's trying to
freeze and now it's boiling
and now watch it'll re-freeze all right
and then it's gonna boil again it's all
three phases
as at exactly the same time so you can
you can google there it is it boiled
again and then it's gonna freeze again
it can do all three at once that is cool
right um and and how do we get there
how did we get there well what i thought
on wednesday was the first time i told
you
there's two new lectures this fall that
was the first time i gave that one that
was one of them the other one will be on
the chemistry of batteries
and because it's new um i i you know i
want to make sure
that you feel your oneness with the
concepts that we learned
and so i have made some summary slides
for you
that i'm not going to take time to go
through but that tells you how we got to
here that's the end of the lecture on
wednesday
and i want to make sure that you know
how we got there and what the key points
were
there are five key points and i've
created a slide here again this is
wednesday so i'm not going to go through
this in detail but i'll leave this in
your notes
one point was boiling and vapor pressure
and what that means the second point is
the vapor pressure versus temperature
which we get from kinetic theory and
clausius clapeyron gives us the
relationship
between that vapor pressure and the
temperature through this thing called
the vaporization the thermal
this remember this change in the thermal
energy
right this delta h this change in
enthalpy
okay and and by the way you could say
and this is these are these like vapor
pressure versus temperature curves we
drew and you can take two of them for
example
that gets rid of the constant in that in
that equation two pressures two vapor
pressures two temperatures
you could calculate the that
vaporization energy that's that
interrelationship we talked about the
third
point is the thermal energy that that
delta h
is related to the phase change it is the
energy of the phase change
right so we talked about that and then i
couldn't find a good
so i just drew this myself here with
fancy powerpoint
and what you can see here is a heating
curve and you can try it in two
different ways you could draw it as the
temperature versus enthalpy
or you could draw it as the energy input
versus temperature these are equivalent
it's just
right and then but in this you can find
all so much information like there's
that delta h between the phases
right here's uh the liquid phase the gas
the solid
and then if you're in a single phase we
talked about that change
in enthalpy related to the heat capacity
if you're at the phase change the
temperature doesn't change
but you're putting a lot of energy into
it and that finally got us
to phase diagrams this is where we left
off so so i'm leaving this all here for
you to look at if you want
it's kind of a summary of wednesday's
lecture uh the key points
um this is that two-phase curve right
and this is
on these curves remember the phase
diagram is a map
it's this beautiful map of a material
right
it's a map of of of the chemistry of the
thermodynamics of the phases of whether
it's a gas liquid or solid and
these coexistence curves are where two
phases coexist
right so you see at these temperatures
and pressures and that that's what
that's
why we started the lecture talking about
vapor pressure
because the vapor pressure is such a
nice way to get
into the idea of how how a material
changes face
from uh liquid to gas which is what we
did um
and then you we also talked about how
that triple point that's the video that
we left off with
and then there's one last thing i didn't
mention which is that you know there's
this critical point here
what's happening out there well what's
happening out there is really
interesting too
there is a temperature right above which
so there is if you keep going up in
temperature there's a critical point
where this boundary just disappears it
stops
does it the liquid there's the liquid in
the gas and now there's no line
look what happened well what happened is
you've reached a temperature
where it it basically can't exist as a
liquid anymore
if you keep going the thermal energy is
just too high
yeah but but the pressure is too high
too so so this is a different
phase and this phase it out here is
called supercritical
this is called supercritical where the
material has properties
of both that's really cool right so this
material
has maybe properties like it can flow
like a gas
right but it's got a higher density than
a gas but it's still lighter than a
liquid
right and it's that same material it's
that same material whatever it is
water right that's called supercritical
so these
these lines can end like that and those
are that's called the critical point
now um there you know there are many
reasons why these maps are important i
thought i'd give you one
which is strawberries because if you go
and you buy for you some
some of us like to buy like dried fruit
but if i take strawberries and i leave
them out on the counter
they're not going to look like this you
know
how do you know that well you know that
from the phase diagram because if i draw
my temperature and pressure and i've got
some phase diagram that looks
like this right
and so now you know solid liquid gas
well you know i i could if i just dr if
i just tried to dry these things
out it's that's this
that's that but so i'm maybe you know
maybe i'm gonna or maybe i'm gonna do
this oh that's even worse
what if i go like this i'm gonna heat
the strawberries up i'm making jam
no that's not jam right that's nice kind
of
maybe still solid it's not like mushy
and
gooey how do i get it well you use the
phase diagram of course
you go because this kind of this kind of
phase change going across that phase
boundary
it creates a lot of disruption in the
material
it creates a lot of disruption you saw
it right that's boiling
so if you if you do that for the water
inside of the strawberries
you're going to destroy all the all the
the the framework
of the of the good stuff right
so what you do is you freeze it you go
this way
and then you go that way if you do that
now the solid as it
sublimates is much less of a kind of
violent
disturbing phenomena to the surrounding
matrix of strawberry
and so you get these freeze-dried fruit
that way it's it's a much
less disturbing destructive way to get
rid of the water that's called free time
you can also go the other you know if i
go out here i've got all sorts of uses
to use the supercritical region i've got
all sorts of ways
where that becomes useful that's how
coffee is decaffeinated because it's a
different phase of this material
so the phase maps give us this
information they tell us
how we can engineer properties and
materials
by engineering their phases right
and and and if you pull out another
thing you know that
a lot of the textbooks and what we did
is we look at the phase diagram down
here but if you pull out you also can
see
how complex materials are all right this
is this is water
we've been focusing on this part of the
phase diagram now you pull out your
water has 17 phases
17 not three
and just two years ago the 17th was
discovered and it's a very very light
form of ice
all right so you can get all sorts of
really important information about
materials by looking at their face
arguments you compare different
materials like this
is the phase diagram of co2 versus water
and you can learn about sort of where
their critical points are
you can see oh the slope here in water
is
most materials slope like that and water
slopes like that
and that's because of hydrogen bonds
because the hydrogen bonds make it so
that the solid
is less dense than the then the liquid
which means if i squeeze on it
i can you know then i go to the liquid
that's really weird if i squeeze on this
it's more soft but here it goes it can
cross a face boundary
that's very unique to water and the fish
are very happy about that because
ice floats okay now
okay now so that's the kind of last part
of the phase diagram stuff
you